WALKS US
THROUGH THE TRINLECT
MURDGHS THE 14'd CIRCUIT
SOLICITOR.
RAS ME LAW FOR YEARS 3 S
3200 SQUAROW
COUNTRY. >>N LAW
THAT IN CRIMINAL JUSTICE THERE
IS NO FIGU THAN
E PROSECUTOR
>> Reporter: THE FAMD L ENFORNT
>> PROBABLY KNOWH OTHER
PRETTY WELL SOT IS THE CAS
>> Reporter: THE GRIP ON
OFFIR ENDED IF 2005 WHEN
RANDOLPHDAIII TIRED  HAD OIC INE
53-YEAR-OLD ALEX KNOWN AS
OF RARTY FRIENDS
EACH EVENIE HEADED HOME TO
THE E ESTA
.
COULD WANT.
UNTIL
>>
H HE RETURNEDO FINDIFE
>> ARE THEY H.
>> N>> OKA
YOU ID YR WIFE ASON?
Y
>> Reporter:2-YEAR-O MAGGIE
MURDAUGH SHOT MULTIHELLO
22-YEAR-OLD PAUL
SHOT AT T TWICE WITH A THE GRUE
PLAYED A LE.
R.
TWO WEAPS,WO
SUT N PLANNED CANO
T ANINVESTIGATOR TO  O BED AWAR
THAT'S PUBLICLY AVAILABLE.
T UP THE OWN ALEX MURDAUGH
,0ARD FO
INFOBUT  BOTTOM E
IS AN ODD CATCH.E TISUBMITTED E
SEPTEMBER 30th.
EVER HEARD OF AN EXP REWARD?
MOER>> Rte ON ROLINA SON AN
THEYAID PAUL HAD BEEG
ATAGTHINA
IFT HAVE
E BUT I GUESS, YOU KNOW,
FAMILY SAAFTER TAING
>>11, WHERNCY?T CRASH ONS
CREEK.
>> WHA MISSING.
>>epCAROLINA
PAUL MURH  FRIENDS
TH A A N ONGHTR AN
EVERYONE GETS INTO A
TOLDGA
PAUL WASVING.
BOAT STRUCK A BRIDGE AT HI
SPEED.
19-YOL
THROWN INTE WATER. >> HELP!
>> PLEASND SOMEONE.
>>HE
>> ALL RISE.
CHARGED WITH BOATI UNDERHE
INFLUENCE RESULTING IN DEATH
HE PLEADED NOT GUILTY.
THE SERIOU
STILL PENDAT THE T
DASH CAM RNGRASH A
CAPTUR T VOICE O
PASSENGER SUGGESTING PAUL WASN'T
LIKELY TO FACE SERIOUS
NOALEX MURDAUGH?
>> I KNOW THE NAME.
>> THAT'S HIS SON.
>> DRIVING THE BOAT.
>> Reporr: THE FIRST TIM
SOMEONE SUGGE MURDAUGH
NAME TO INFLTC
AN INVEST.
RDERS THERE WAS UNNINGDURIHEY
SAID THEY FOUND SOMETHING.
T SAY WHAT B THEY
WERE GOING TO REOPEN AN
INVESTIGATION INTO ANOTHUNSOLVE.
>> WHERE IYO EOWN TH I
SE LAYING OUT.
>>LL SEE WHAT'S GOING ON.
>> NOT MOVING.
SOBOHIT IT.
MEOING TO T .
>> Reporter: 19-YEAR-OTEVED DEAE
MIDDLE OF THE ROAD IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE NIGHT JUST OUTSID
LOT OF TALK POLICE S
AND ONE FAMILY NAM
INUSTRATED. E MANY RELUCTANTK AN
>>OT OM NERVOU
E MURD YEAH.SURE.
>> YEAH.
YOU KNOW?
THERE IN HAMPTON BUT I'M OUT OF
LE'T
ANYOU TO FEEL LIKE YOU
orING TO
AN EBB NICLY RELEASED
EVIDENCE LINKS ANYONE IN THE
MURDAUGH FAMILY TO'S
DEATH.
THEN AHO.
SEPTEMBER 3rOF THIS YEAR THE
POWER.
FAMILY L FIRM SAID THEY
SCDOH
ALLEGLY
FUNDS FROM THEOMPANY.
SOURCES SAY IT'S MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
MURDERS OF ANED ANNING
INCRLYFI
I AM ENTERING NGT OFET
TTS EXACERBATED BY THE
MURDERS.
ADDICTIOGGK TO CT  TEAD.
>> Reporter: V EX SAID AS HE STN
TRUCK DROVE PAST ANDNDN A CH PA
ANRE.
MURDAUGHOLE
MAN SHOT HIM IN TH.
HE WAS OUT OF THE HOSPIT TWO
DAYS.
CH TRUCK TURNED THE ANO IN
TH NUMBER OF
SECURITY CAMERAS. LK IN GENERAL
OCCUED WAY AND HER THAT LOOKS IS
THK TURNED AROUND.EO TLD B
CLUES ABOUT A SUSP
D OF THE TI
OF ALEX MURDAUGHWIE
THS FAS ESTIGA H SPENDENDOUS AUN
WINNOWING THROUGH.
ANSO IESter: WITANY NEW
THOUGHT TH KE FRIENDLY LAWYEW W
REALLY KNEW HIM AT ALLW THE
WICE FRAUD.G.
TNS THAT THAT WHO
IREDAPARTHE HEAD MEANT AR ALEXAD
E.
AND THERE IS ANOTHERTIGATION.
HO GLORIA.DOTHE
AND TH IN 2018 SUFFERED A TR
AP  IA NATURAL CAUSE.JUST THEOA
MEANWHILE THE FAMILY WAS  TCEE I